- I've never been nervous
for a BuzzFeed shoot before.
- I think this is gonna suck.
- My name is Rodney,
(whooshing and creaking)
we're gonna be talking
about my mom, Janet.
- My mama, Darlene.
- Mary Helen.
- Cathy.
- My mother, Mei.
- My friends didn't hit on my mom.
Least that I knew of,
oh my gosh, did they?
- We have Cathy.
- Uh, don't even say her name.
(laughing)
- Does she ever go by Cat?
- No.
- Kitty, Kitty Cat?
- Oh God...
- [Man in Purple] Alright,
let's look at some pict-
- Whoa!
- Oh
- Showin' off the goods.
- Let's not call 'em the goods, man.
- I mean, I'm down.
(laughing)
- If they had selfies back in
the day, she could be just all
- Cathy on the bed, Cathy on
the bed, Cathy on the bed.
- She's like...
- Do a little shimmy,
like, let me get this shirt off.
- She would bite on the first date.
- Absolutely!
- Like, you go in...
- You put, I wanna go
down on a knee right now.
- Oh my God.
- I'd be a great step-dad to Zach.
- Oh man.
(laughing)
- I'd be a great one.
- I haven't talked about my
mom in this context before.
About her being sexy, so
I'm kinda weirded out.
- Janet.
- Yup.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh wow.
- Yup.
- Your mom is hot, dude.
- I'm a gay man and I'd ask her out.
- She's just like a sexy woman,
I don't know how to describe it.
- Yeah, like with all due, I didn't think
we were gonna say the word sexy today.
- She gets more sexy...
- As she gets older.
- Yeah, as time goes on, somehow.
- She's like Jennifer Lopez.
Like if this were The Boy Next Door,
- Right?
- I would be the boy next door.
- Wow.
- Creepin' on your mom.
(sultry saxophone music)
My friends never hit on my mom.
'Cause my house was the fun house,
but not because they wanted
to have sex with my mom.
I hope, I don't know, I don't know now.
- Oh man.
- [Zach] Oh man!
- Was this a prom pic?
- These pictures don't even
look that off, like, in time.
- No.
- Like this could have been,
- No, this is the place I was born.
- Like, this was
Thursday, this was Friday.
- She's pure, but is she pure?
- What the heck?
Whoooa
- Yes, yes!
- Are you sure?
- She had sex twice, once
for me, once for my sister.
- I think she could pull
any dude at the bar.
- I believe it.
- She's not looking at you.
- She's looking at me.
Hi.
I'd take her to like the
magic castle or something.
Cool dates, right?
- She would love that.
- Darlene is sexy.
- For me to even think about what my peers
would like about my mom is strange.
- We have Justin's mom, Mei.
- May I?
- Boom.
- Oh, let's go!
- She got like the short shorts going on.
- Yeah yo, your mom's got nice legs.
- In this photo, she looks elegant.
- [Man in Grey] Like a princess.
- Elegant and delicate.
- I'd try to kiss your
mom on the first date,
but I don't know if it'd work.
- She's got the lips, she's got the legs.
- She has a great mouth.
- Yeah.
- Your mom is aging very well.
- Black and Asian don't crack, man.
- Does your mom like Disney World?
- I don't think she's ever been.
- Oh really?
Because I've got a date in mind.
- My mom's a beautiful woman,
but I don't think my friends
saw her as someone to hit on.
- Mary Helen.
- She was probably a nun.
- Sounds like a nun.
- She's clearly not.
- [Both] Whoa!
- Hello, Mary Helen!
- Mary had his Helen.
- This lady's like a teacher that you
maybe had a crush on or something.
- Your mom was a model.
- Oh wow.
- I think she's undercover wild.
- This all-white like jacket, type thing?
Nice, it screams power,
which is very attractive.
- I'm gettin' hot just
looking at this photo, wow.
- She has that glare that just says,
"yeah I'll do you real quick."
- Oh my God!
- No offense to Zach's mom,
- Dang!
- but...
- She can get it.
(groans)
Sorry.
- It was awful.
I don't want to ever hear Rodney say
anything about my mother ever again.
- I was actually surprised that
they didn't go in a lot harder.
- In a way, it's flattering, you know,
it's like, oh, "your mom,
this is where you get it."
You're like, and you're like, "oh, hey."
- The most surprising thing was
that everybody's mom was attractive.
Thank God.
- Hey mom.
- Hi Janet.
- I'll get your number from Rodney
and I, maybe I should give you a call-
- [Rodney] Mom, these guys
want to, like, touch you.
I don't know if you,
- No, I'm not-
- Whoa, whoa!
- Whoa whoa whoa.
- [Janet] Mothers are off limits!
(whooshing and creaking)